still good hey everyone what's happenin
it's mo you go thank you so much to the
love on the last two videos every time I
saw a comment about how excited you all
are about tech and software engineering
it made me so happy so many of you asked
me questions about how I got into tech
and software engineering so today I'm
going to dive in and tell you my story
here we go I never coded before College
my high school never offered computer
science classes and I never thought that
I would be a software engineer ever I
went to college at UC San Diego where I
started my freshman year as undeclared I
actually was considering being like a
chemistry or neuroscience major but I
took an intro course in each and I
quickly noped out of there because I
realized it worked for me I was hanging
out with my door friends one day when
one of them suggested I try computer
science he was a CS major himself and he
said that with my logically minded brain
and my desire to do something science e
computer science would be perfect for me
he also mentioned that there's more
software engineering jobs than there are
software engineers and as someone who
really wanted to have job security and
be financially stable right after
college that sounded really awesome on
this point in my freshman year I was
basically willing to try anything
because of my two failed attempts that
declared my major previously to find out
a little bit more about computer science
I went to the campus library to do some
research and my research I mean check
out any books that have the word
computers or software in them or
anything that had code I thought through
them to see if I would enjoy absorbing
the information that was presented in
these books I wasn't exactly like oh my
gosh licked list you like the coolest
thing how did no one tell me about them
but I was having a much easier time
absorbing the information than I did my
chemistry and violet literally the next
day I find it for my intro to computer
science class and after getting through
that class and being like that wasn't do
that I think I can do more I declared my
major is computer science
after taking a couple more classes and
becoming friends with my classmates and
tutors
it became clear to me that internships
are pivotal in getting a job after
college
never preface I works part-time jobs all
through college to support myself
financially until my freshman year I
worked at Jamba Juice and the campus
bookstore in my second year I found a
job at UCSD department of biomedical
informatics they were a department that
uses data analytics to sequence genes to
help save people
pretty cool stuff I started working
there as an office assistant being paid
close to minimum wage helping organize
file and folders and also helping with
the conferences that the division put on
I knew they had a summer internship
program so it's hoping this job would
serve as a foot in the door to that
program when the internship program
started accepting applications I want to
go talk to the program lead and he gave
me a spot in the program thanks my foot
in the door technique my project there
was to create a webpage that would help
scientists visualize the data that
they're getting I use a lot of
JavaScript frameworks and PHP
looking back on it I literally had like
a 2,000 line PHP brow because I didn't
really know what I was doing but that's
okay because I learned a ton about
software development after my
three-month internship ended I gained
some confidence and that I could
actually build something that people
would use and so now I wanted to use my
skills to something that I was more
personally interested in at the time I
was watching a lot of Doctor Who and
Neil deGrasse Tyson and Carl Sagan and
so my next endeavor was going to be
space my friend actually had an
internship on campus that was run by the
Sally Ride Foundation Sally Ride was the
first American woman in space and her
company was hiring I went to the typical
interview process where I talked through
my resume and talked about different
projects that I worked on and I got the
job I think it was actually one of my
coolest jobs to date not only was I
finally being able to use my coding
skills for something that I was
interested in but we have like this cool
Mission Control Room were rebranded
missions for the project that was called
Grail boot camp there I made a Java
based game intended to teach middle
school students how this grilll
spacecraft worked it was a lot of
object-oriented programming and learning
how to use Javas rendering library Java
2d swing
this job is also great because I can
work during the school year part-time
while I was continuing my studies now
summer was approaching quickly and at
this point I was my third year of
college I really wanted some experience
working at a big tech company since I
set my eyes on working at one right
after I graduated I went to the tech
daubrey on campus and faced rejection
after rejection
Pandya all met resumes after lots of
applying and interviewing at tech
companies and also applying through my
friends who worked at them I got an
internship at Intuit
a financial software company that makes
TurboTax during my 3 month internship
there I worked on TurboTax calm and used
a lot of JavaScript and HTML and I
learned a lot about software development
and processes and after that was then I
went back to school for my fourth and
final year of college I successfully
graduated from UCSC in 2014 my
bachelor's in computer science let us
take a step back and I know I'm really
fortunate to say that but college is one
of the hardest things that I've ever
done I worked part-time to support
myself financially and I was also a part
of a lot of student organizations to
network and also how the community of
friends who were also studying
engineering balancing all of that with a
branded computer science curriculum was
really tough but I somehow made it
through and it's still one of my
proudest accomplishments to date I
rejoined into it after I graduated and
was part of a two-year rotational
program that would give me the
opportunity to rotate between different
teams and projects and products and work
on different technologies especially
because I didn't really know whether I
wanted to work on web or mobile backend
or apron stuff quite yet it just so
happened that my first rotation was on a
TurboTax iOS team where I had my very
first introduction to mobile programming
which I still do today I was fortunate
enough to join an awesome team that
showed me how fun working be and how
rewarding it is to work on a project
that has a positive impact on people's
lives when my rotation ended I decided I
wanted to move up to Silicon Valley to
be fully embedded in the tech world and
also experience what it's like to be a
software engineer working at the ballet
I thought maybe this is like Hollywood
for actors or like Broadway from
pinnacle stars so I was really excited I
felt so excited to be taking such a big
step in my career and I've head first
into the tech world I still work that
into it but I work from there Bay Area
office and I was still doing mobile
development after my rotation ended and
writing a lot of Swiss code I decided
that I wanted to write something other
than financial software I just so
happened to stumble upon a job opening
at patreon a company that creates a
membership platform makes it easy for
creators to get PDM membership tools and
recurring funding for their fans since
I've always loved the YouTube community
and always loved to music growing up I
saw this and I thought I have to have
this job and so I submitted my resume
that name day an interview with a
typical three-stage interview process
the phone screen the technical phone
screen or take home project and the on
site and I got the job this felt like
getting my dream job and everything I
had done led up to this point and this
job fast forward to now I still work at
patreon as an Iowa engineer helping to
build patreon Iowa's apps I absolutely
love what I do
and it's awesome to be a part of a
project that helps fund the emergent
creative class so that's it that's been
my career path so far it's been
highlighted with a lot of hard work a
lot of asking myself what would make me
happy to apply my skills to and constant
change and I'm really proud of how far
I've come
needless to say there are so many
different paths and ways of getting into
software engineering that are so
different from my own several of my
friends have had completely different
journeys into software engineering that
are different from my own and they're
all achieving their goals and dreams
mine is just one data point that I hope
will help you somehow
there isn't one right way to get into
software engineering so go with your gut
and do what you're passionate about
thank you so much for watching again
thank you to every single one of you who
compensator reached out to me based on
my last two videos like I said in my
previous video my content to hopefully
help foster a interest or career in
technology and so it really means so
much to me that you all are enjoying
some content if you have any questions
for me at all threes don't hesitate to
leave a comment down below or reach out
to me via Twitter or Instagram and if
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to my channel if
you'd like to see more anyways I hope
you all have a great day
I wonder how level my head oh it's like
a game
[Music]